bonjour saga sur les enfants 4 s'agace
ça donne ça gâche aller faire des
courses
la porte et petits cadeaux alors tiens
donnera sa des copains je peux leur
donner tout de suite
et puis j'ai apporté des gâteaux pour
miss 4 frags adage n'apportait de alors
malheureusement j'ai demandé aux
boulangers qui me donne des deux gâteaux
là un peu de la même taille mais il y en
a pas trouvé il avait un gros et un
petit alors comme vous vous débrouillez
vous entre vous lille ont l'air très bon
tous les deux sont bons qu'est ce que tu
as tout sur toi nous nous jetons prix de
biscottes sers toi
la première bon bon bah voilà
non mais n'ont pas eu pourquoi si tu
veux question monsieur qui aurait pris
le petit tuyau à bondues tu crois ça oui
bien sûr si je crois j'en suis sûr tu
n'es pas vu qu'à tampa mal élevés je
trouve qu'il ya quelque chose de vrai
dans ce que dit mais ce catamaran dans
dans le fond 1
j'ai bien compris si j'étais poli je
prendrai le petit et je te laisserai le
gros impact man et ils toi et tu bien
élevé oumali aujourd'hui une très bonne
éducation et j'estime je suis bien donc
si tu avais dû choisir en premier
tu aurais pris lequel il aurait pris le
petit libyen et bien mascotte du lait le
petit alors de quoi te plains tu as un
bon vraiment
tous
dans les combines aller
dans mon sac car une plaque de bons
chocolats dans le mon sac à une plaque
de chocolat jetons donne pas je n'en
veux pas pour toi pour toi mais quand on
sent copains tu auras tout ou presque
tout du canton cinq copains dont autres
où il ya des sous pour acheter des
choses
transat ou bien des sous pour acheter
des choses je tombe donne pas je te
donne pour pour toi mais contre son
copain
à doha tout presque tous quand son
copain dans le frigo ya des pots avec de
la glace dans le jeu tente donne pas
pour toi ô pour toi mais quand on chante
copain
un ton bras tout ratant presque tous
risques quand un copain dans le buffet y
des jouets mec avec annick buffet jetant
donne pas autant pas c'est pourquoi je
crois pour toi mais quand on sent
copains tu auras tout presque tous pour
un peu quand dans son code pin
dans mon cou il ya des points qui font
la culbute dans mon cou ya des pots qui
font la culbute en termes de poids pour
toi mais quand on sera repeint tu auras
toujours ou presque toutes tendances un
copain canton son copain